[Music]  [Music]  show me show me show me how you do that  trick the one that makes me scream she  said  the one that makes me laugh she said  through her arms around my neck  show me how you do it  and i promise that  i promise that i'll run away with you  i'll run away with you  [Music]  spinning on that dizzy edge kiss her  face and kiss her head and dream of all  the different ways  [Music]  why are you so far away she said why  won't you ever know that i'm in love  [Music]  strange's angels dancing in the deepest  oceans twisting in the water just like a  dream  you're just like a dream  [Music]  do  [Music]  daylight swept me into shape i must have  been asleep for days moving lips to  breathe her name i opened  [Music]  raging sea that stole the only girl i  loved and drowned deep inside of me  you  [Music]  soft and only you  lost and lonely  you  just like heaven  [Music]  [Applause]  you